How do you stay motivated and how do you motivate people when they start to
slack?
Now motivation is,
it's kind of a strange word because it doesn't really mean what we think it
means.
We think it means that we're fired up to do something.
We think that it means we're eager and passionate to make something happen
and we think that somehow we should just be able to turn on that eagerness and
turn on that passion.
But we can't
because you just can't turn on passion.
You can't just turn on the desire to execute.
A task
just doesn't work that way.
And honestly that isn't even what motivate means.
Motivate doesn't mean to yell and scream and encourage.
No,
to motivate actually means to provide a motive.
A reason why.
So to motivate someone is to explain to them why they're doing what they're
doing,
how it will help them,
where it'll take them,
why they should continue to work and a struggle and a fight.
And when you need motivation yourself,
well look for someone to scream and yell.
Don't look for someone else to give you motivation.
Look at yourself,
look at yourself.
And remind yourself why,
why you are doing what you are doing.
Remind yourself that this struggle,
this temporary pain,
this fight,
this fight that you're in,
this is what will make you stronger and faster and smarter
and better
in them.
With that motivation,
go forward
into the fray,
into the storm,
into the heat of the battle
where victory is forged.